here's an interesting polynomials
question for this X cube minus KX plus 1
equals 0 polynomial if it has exactly
one root between x equals not and x
equals 1 then being that K is some
arbitrary constant explain why to minus
K must be negative now this is an
interesting question because at the
beginning you think we're how do I even
style what kind of way can I approach
this and you might think well okay what
if imagine that tell you well there's
exactly one root so that might tip you
to think I have something to do with the
discriminant you know I think for some
kinds of functions if the discriminant
is zero you get exactly one root but
then you would have a problem with that
which is that this is a cubic so you're
actually probably thing here quadratics
when this comes into your mind the
discriminant for the cubic is not
actually even something that you
expected to know and there's a good
reason for that it's because it's equal
to this this long awkward formula based
on the coefficients of the cubic
polynomial so when you think about this
you're like okay this is not a result I
meant to know the discriminant is
probably not going to help me with this
okay then you might think well maybe
calculus might be able to help me okay
if I differentiate this graph X cubed
minus KX plus one then that's going to
give you three x squared minus K okay
and when you think about this it's a the
leading coefficient is one so what kind
of cubic is it well if it's got exactly
one root it's going to look either like
this sorry this between it's between 0
and 1 so scratch that it might look like
this or alternatively 0 and 1 it might
look like this ok so what conclusions
could you draw well the derivative is
either 0 or it's positive so you could
say 3 x squared minus K is greater than
or equal to 0 within that domain but
that doesn't help you very much either
because you've got this K there and you
do have an inequality but there's an X
in there and you think well what am I
going to do with this so
des scratch your head a little longer
and think okay it's not something to do
with the discriminant it's not something
to do with calculus what else could it
be
this is polynomials and in extension one
the other kinds of things you know about
polynomials are well you know there's
this thing called Newton's methods for
approximating roots which uses calculus
this above and you also know there's a
thing called the bisection method or
having the interval which is about the
same thing finding or approximating
roots so the question is either of these
useful to us and the answer is well they
definitely are but the question is which
one well you're trying to show that
something is negative yes now which of
these methods techniques algorithms has
anything to do with positive or negative
and the answer is it's the bisection
method if you can't remember the way the
bisection method works is by saying look
if you have some kind of function okay
and you know it passes through the axis
somewhere okay so it has a root then you
call it alpha well on the left if you
test out that value you should get some
positive value and on the right for this
one you should get some kind of negative
value or obviously you could have the
reverse scenario and it could be doing
this so on the left you'll have a
negative value of some kind and on the
right you'll have a positive value some
kind whatever a thing you've got you've
got a change in sign before and after
where you expect this root to be okay so
therefore since I know the question told
me that the root is between x equals
naught and x equals 1 that should have
been my clue to say all right I can use
this I can take advantage of these two
facts here or one factor it's two parts
to it to work out a relationship between
the roots and its K thing in this
positive negative business okay so let's
let's put it back a little bit let's so
let's give this polynomial name let's
call it P it's X cubed minus K X plus 1
okay and I know that there's a root
between 0 and 1 okay so let's see what
happens at 0
again zero qj-- which is zero - Kade
lots of zero which is zero plus one so
it's equal to one now what that tells me
is that P naught is positive right so
before the route that I'm expecting I'm
above the axis so that means after the
route I should be expecting it to be
below the axis should be expecting this
right because that's I know between here
and here it passes through the x-axis so
I can say well P of 1 will be less than
zero what is P of 1
it's 1 cubed minus K lots of sorry this
is come back a little bit so that's
greater than 0 or less than 0 okay come
back this one cubed minus K lots of one
plus one that's less than zero it's
negative so that's 1 minus K plus 1
which is necessary and that's the to
minus K being negative that we were
required to prove okay so in conclusion
how do you approach this question you
need to really take into account all of
the information they've given you that
there's a root it's between here and
here okay
and so when you're trying to work out a
positive negative value that's a strong
inclination that you need to go towards
the bisection method or the Harvey
interval because that's what it depends
on that method it depends on the
positive negative transition that
happens before and after a root